würden sie denken dass sie sich mit den
menschen die jetzt hier im raum sind
eher verständigen als mit den 50
jährigen aus der fdp also ich glaube man
muss schon unterscheiden
generationengerechtigkeit bedeutet ja
auch dass man
generationenkonflikte gemeinsam angeht
und dass man gemeinsam eine gute zukunft
schafft und natürlich mache ich das auch
zusammen mit älteren in der fdp das ganz
wichtig nichtsdestotrotz gibt es auch
häufig unter jungen politikerinnen und
politikern das habe ich erlebt einen
sehr großen großes verlangen nach
veränderungen nach zukunft dinge zu
gestalten und nicht alles so zu belassen
wie es ist und dagegen glaube ich die
ideen und unterschiedliche richtungen
aber dass etwas passieren muss dass man
sich häufig unter den jungen einig und
dann werden wir das genau prüfen heute
hajo schumacher ist bei uns geschätzt
der journalist und kollege autor vater
zweier söhne darf ich sagen unsere
generation hajo schumacher wir sind im
grunde genommen die turbo umweltsünde
fühlt man sich dafür verantwortlich
sogar mit schuldig also die schuldfrage
ist nur eine nummer zu groß fakt ist
dass wir natürlich auf die kosten der
nachfolgenden generation gelebt haben
ich bin in dem alter der der studiogäste
mit dem rucksack kreuz und quer durch
südostasien
möglich dann auch in jedem semester
finden also mein co2 fußabdruck der eso
riesengroß dann können wir alle zusammen
drin waren ich wusste es damals nämlich
besser und das ist ein bisschen das
problem wir hätten viel es eigentlich
schon wissen können es war glaube ich
1971 als der club of rome diesen
legendären bericht die folgen des
wachstums veröffentlicht hat da stand
alles schon drin was wir heute
diskutieren und das ist ein bisschen
unser problem wir kennen wir kennen die
herausforderungen aber wir reagieren so
langsam und das ist die große
herausforderung für unser liberales
demokratisches system sind wir
eigentlich noch in der lage vielleicht
ja mit diesen jungen abgeordneten die
probleme dann auch irgendwann mal
anzugehen weil das klima wartet glaube
ich nicht noch 50 jahre
mit mit seinen folgen bis wir endlich
mal in die puschen kommen da ist auch
die systemfrage im raum und wir begrüßen
doch mirko drotschmann der uns aus
düsseldorf zugeschaltet ist heute auch
ein geschätzter journalist und kollege
moderator im zdf youtuber sowieso eher
drotschmann sie waren mit dem abi gerade
fertig als 2005 angela merkel
bundeskanzlerin wurde was würden sie
sagen war das größte dingen dass sie
liegen gelassen hat
ja stimmt ich hatte auch meinen ersten
job in dem zusammenhang das war direkt
nach der bundestagswahl habe ich eine
umfrage gemacht unter jungen leuten was
sie sich denn erwarten von der neuen
regierung unter angela merkel
und was da immer wieder genannt wurde
das war nicht der klimaschutz er war
2005 bei jungen leuten noch nicht so
groß auf der agenda das war tatsächlich
das thema digitales der netzausbau wurde
immer wieder angesprochen und das war
auch eine erwartung die ich hatte und
die bitter enttäuscht wurde wenn man
sich mal anschaut wie viel
glasfaserkabel in deutschland liegen das
sind glaube ich um die 5% der
oecd-schnitt liegt aktuell bei 30
prozent schweden ist fernab irgendwo
gleich bei 75 also das war ein thema das
glaube ich in dieser zeit stark
vernachlässigt wurde da mag man sagen es
gibt viele andere viel wichtigere und
größere themen aber zumindest war das
für uns damals eins der der großen und
wichtigen themen und der klimaschutz ist
natürlich dann mit der zeit auch immer
größer geworden wenn man das so sagen
kann würde ich sagen angela merkel war
und ist eine kanzlerin der stabilität
aber sie ist eine kanzlerin die für das
heute regiert sie hat mit vielen krisen
zu kämpfen gehabt wirtschaftskrise 2008
dann die flüchtlinge ab 2015 wenn man
das als krise bezeichnen darf die korona
krise und andere kleinere probleme in
anführungszeichen sie hat für das heute
regiert und dabei würde ich sagen zu
wenig an die zukunft an das morgen
gedacht da geht es um digitalisierung da
geht es um soziale gerechtigkeit da geht
es aber auch natürlich um den
klimaschutz schon 1995 gesagt wir müssen
den klimaschutz energisch anpacken das
hat man dann wären ihre regierungszeit
wenig gemerkt das heißt machte eben auch
eine politik nicht für die junge
generation sondern für die dann 40 bis
ja das könnte man so unterstellen das
ist natürlich auch die kernzielgruppe
der union
im bundestag gibt es ein
durchschnittsalter von 49
über ja ich glaube mehr als die hälfte
der über 80-jährigen hat bei der letzten
wahl die union gewählt da ist es nicht
zu verübeln dass man vielleicht eher mal
auf diese zielgruppe schaut aber es
hängt natürlich auch mit der
gegenwärtigen politischen situation
zusammen mit den problemen mit denen man
da zu kämpfen hat aber sicher hat man
eine jüngere zielgruppe immer jüngere
menschen doch lange vernachlässigt und
das rächt sich jetzt los geht's hier
haben wir jetzt die junge zielgruppe und
werden handlos gleich noch mal fragen
wie er so sein altersdurchschnitt in
hamburg gestartet gestaltet hat wir sind
bei dem großen thema klimaschutz da
sagen interessanterweise frau rosenthal
die spd und die cdu dass sie einen
moderaten oder auch variiert einen
maßvollen weg zum klimaschutz wählen
wollen erscheint ihnen das realistisch
wenn man sich diese irrsinnigen ziele
anguckt dass man das maß voll machen
kann und moderat naja also da muss ich
sagen völlig also sehe ich das spd
wahlprogramm nicht richtig zusammen
gefasst weil ich glaube schon dass es
auch zwischen cdu und spd den großen
unterschied gibt wir sagen nämlich mit
welchen instrumenten wir das erreichen
wollen und maßvoll würde ich sagen ist
nicht der richtige weg sondern mit aller
kraft das muss jetzt der weg sein das
heißt eben mehr gehalt die parteien
gerade beschlossen haben noch in der
großen koalition ist ja eine
verdreifachung der geschwindigkeit was
man erreichen will bei der co2
einsparung also wir müssen im grunde all
das was wir bisher gemacht haben dreimal
schneller machen um diese ziele zu
erreichen
ja auf jeden fall müssen wir diese ziele
müssen uns müssen wir den ganzen weg
beschleunigen das sind ja genau die
fragen von wie schaffen wir die
energiewende wie kommen wir denn bei den
erneuerbaren energien kann wie schaffen
wir dass die windräder schneller
aufgebaut wenn das überhaupt mal
aufgebaut dass die stromtrasse die wir
jetzt auch noch erdkabeln wollen endlich
gebaut wird von nord nach süd das sind
ja alles die fragen die jetzt
schnellstmöglich umgesetzt werden müssen
und da muss mehr tempo passieren
natürlich auch aus der sicht von uns als
jusos von jungen menschen und ich glaube
aber da kommt es eben darauf an die die
instrumente sich anzugucken und auch zu
sagen welche vorschläge da im raum
stehen und da glaube ich nur auf den
markt zu setzen und zu sein nur der co2
preis ist das richtige dass es nicht
maßvoll und das ist auch nicht der
richtige weg sondern wir müssen gucken
dass wir zwischen regulatorischen
eingriffen zwischen marktmechanismen an
den stellen wo es sinnvoll ist und
entlastungen damit man den weg zur
arbeit auch noch leisten kann das alles
hinkriegt und gleichzeitig investiert
und das da gibt es keine frage von
bremse da muss volles tempo gemacht
werden frau schröder wenn man der cdu zu
wort und der fdp dann gehen beide
parteien davon aus dass man sich im
grunde aus dieser not heraus erfindet
und dass der markt das alleine regelt
glauben sie wirklich dass das so sein
wird warum hätte er es dann nicht schon
längst getan dieser mal ein beispiel bei
montech die forschung an diesem
impfstoff den ging schon viele jahre in
die jahre aber die not groß war da war
das geld da waren die ressourcen dar und
dann wurde entsprechend investiert und
dann hatten wir auch einen
entsprechenden impfstoff und das war ja
der große game changer in der korona
krise und ich will dass der nächste game
changer für die klimakrise dass er auch
aus deutschland kommt und da bin ich
fest von überzeugt dass wir es reicht
nicht nichts zu tun also freiwilligkeit
ist gut aber wir brauchen einen festen
rahmen der ermöglicht dass die
marktwirtschaftlichen mechanismen die
wir haben auch wirken können und das ist
ein co2 limit und co2 deckel der sich
orientiert an dem budget was wir noch
ausstossen dürfen und das ist und dann
gehen das ist nicht mehr viel in der tat
und ich glaube deswegen werden wir da
ganz schnell ganz große bedürfnisse auch
haben in der wirtschaft in den
unternehmen zu investieren und damit
auch die dringend benötigten
innovationen voranzubringen und das will
ich betonen also diese innovation die
haben ja den großen vorteil dass sie
nicht nur deutschland klimaneutral
machen sondern dass die weltweit zum
klimaschutz bei müssen die aber
eigentlich jetzt schon erfunden haben
damit sie möglichst schnell greifen
können aber ich mach mal ein beispiel
wir haben ja auch einige also wir haben
ja einige innovationen schon in
deutschland empfunden photovoltaik
beispielsweise also wir sprechen ja
nicht um über irgendwelche total
absurden ideen in eine neue
energiequelle die wir heute noch gar
nicht haben sondern es geht darum zum
beispiel die technologien die wir haben
zu verbessern speichertechnologien auch
im bereich von food deckt beispielsweise
gentechnik ist ein riesen
quell von innovation und da weiter zu
forschen das auch in deutschland zu
machen wir haben hier nämlich die
universitäten die das können wir haben
die forschenden unternehmen da ist dass
wir die von lamin jaiteh für die
innovation wir sind frau heinrich bei
der großen frage der grünen die in
natürlich immer vermeiden wollten auch
in diesem wahlkampf vermeiden wollten
als verbots partei dazustehen weil das
ist ja die alternative zu sagen wir
müssen im übrigen auch gar nicht mehr so
viel wachsen an einzelnen stellen
nämlich bei unserem verbrauch und wir
müssen manche dinge vielleicht sogar
verbieten so und nun hat annalena
baerbock ausgerechnet dieses wort in den
mund genommen und gesagt jedes verbot
ist auch ein
innovationstreiber das klingt nicht so
richtig freuen ja aber ich würde sagen
das worum es geht ist wenn man an
bestimmten stellen lässt wenn man ohne
co2 grenze setzt setzt man eine grenze
oder eines klar ab dem punkt ist schluss
da muss etwas anderes passieren ich bin
kein fan davon dass alles nur über den
preis zu regeln also wenn wir wirklich
sagen würde wir wollten wirklich alles
einpreisen wie teuer also wieviel gerade
zerstört wird durch das klima wie teuer
das für uns alle wird dann können wir
halt dem co2 preis auch im bereich von
mehreren hundert euro ansetzen oder noch
schlimmer also wenn man das ehrlich
machen würde ich würde sagen das ist
ganz schön schlimm denn das wird dann
wirklich unsozial im gegensatz dazu
haben wir mit neun jahren redet man von
verboten andere sagen ordnungspolitik ja
die möglichkeit dafür zu sorgen ok
bestimmte alternativen die haben ihr
ende sie sollten eigentlich früher seien
zum beispiel der kohleausstieg der muss
20 30 kommt aber wir brauchen eben nicht
nur das ende der einen sondern wir
müssen vor allem fragen wie die anderen
ausgebaut werden was ist denn mit den
leuten die dann irgendwie in der kleinen
stadt wohnen und dann haben sie hat
nicht das geld dann ist der co2 preis
sehr hoch dann sitzen sie da einfach um
bei dann können sie sich den benzin
nicht mehr leisten aber es wird auch
kein bus es wert auch keine bahn und das
elektroauto kann man sich auch nicht
kaufen also ich würde sagen ein sehr
hoher co2 preis ohne alles andere sorgt
dafür dass co2 vielleicht eingespart
wird aber dadurch dass leute elendig
leben müssen und das finde ich nicht
erstrebenswert sie erinnerte auch klar
wir haben zum beispiel auch eine klima
dividende im programm die wir glaube ich
auch einige von euren parteien einen
sozialen ausgleich schafft und man muss
ja sehen wenn wir einfach nur co2 teurer
machen und nichts passieren würde ja
dann würde alles teurer werden aber in
dem dann ja auch dinge die heute im
vergleich zu unserer herkömmlichen
wirtschaftsweise die heute noch teuer
sind die wären dadurch natürlich
günstiger die werden mir nachgefragt und
dadurch entstehen natürlich auch neue
märkte und natürlich gibt es ein
interesse auch von unternehmen auch
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern
günstige angebote zu machen und dadurch
also ich glaube wir müssen mal ein
bisschen mehr einerseits zumuten den
menschen die situation zu verstehen und
ihnen zu sagen da kommt was auf uns zu
das wird nicht maßvoll sondern wir haben
die aufgabe unsere gesamte lebensweise
von co2 intensiv auf klimaneutral
umzustellen ist eine große aufgabe das
können wir zusammen helfen aber wir
müssen die effektiven instrumente die
wir kennen auch wirklich so ist ist ja
auch so ein schlagwort wie sie fragen
herrn plus x
stichwort kann man nicht wirklich auch
mit staatlichen eingriffen mit
regulierungen innovation treiben
beispiel bei der bei der autoindustrie
war der katalysator war der
sicherheitsgurt natürlich einen von der
politik festgelegten
eine festgelegte grenze oder ein
festgelegtes ziel braucht es nicht diese
eingriffe des staates auch natürlich
sagt die politik immer was es erlaubt
und was es nicht erlaubt aber hier geht
es ja um eine grundsätzliche kultur und
ein grundsätzliches herangehen und bei
den grünen hat man es beim trial
wiedergesehen annalena baerbock hat es
ja klar gesagt man hat es jetzt eben
auch wieder gehört dass die grünen
wirklich denken mit verboten erreichen
sie die ziele und sie haben eben die
automobilindustrie genannt da kann man
ja gerade sehen dass verbote nicht das
beste mittel sind denn unternehmen wie
tesla ist doch nicht in der
verbotskultur entstanden sondern in
einer kultur in der
marktwirtschaftlichen regeln gab in der
sich unternehmen in falten konnten in
der unternehmergeist belohnt wurde und
in dem es anreize gab zu investieren und
das ist doch das was wir auch brauchen
also wir haben auch diskussionen ja von
den grünen initiiert vom fliegen
verboten werden soll ich glaube dass es
die völlig falsche herangehensweise wir
sollten fliegen nicht verbieten sondern
wir sollten fliegen klimaneutral machen
zum beispiel mit dem wind an unseren
norddeutschen küsten oder mit der sonne
aus bayern und das muss unser ansatz
sein und ich möchte noch einen punkt
hinzufügen weil das habe ich jetzt so
bei allen herausgehört immer eine sehr
nationale sichtweise ich glaube gerade
beim thema klimaschutz wenn wir nur
erfolgreich sein wenn wir international
ran denn wenn wir jetzt hier eine
sonderregelung machen für alle deutschen
unternehmen dann kostet das
arbeitsplätze dann wird das land
teilweise deindustrialisiert und dann
werden unternehmen nach asien oder in
die usa wandern teilweise wird dann dort
zum beispiel für die stahlproduktion
oder für die kupferproduktion noch viel
mehr co2 verursacht und das kann nicht
unser ansatz seiner haben wir hier ein
sozial gespaltenes land eine extreme
frustration in der bevölkerung viele
schicksale und ich möchte dass wir aus
dem thema klimaschutz ein erfolgsmodell
machen auch neue arbeitswelt zensuren
dann ist trotzdem die frage wer kann
sich diesen klimaschutz leisten darum
geht es natürlich und darüber muss auch
immer wenn man daraus eine arbeitsplätze
schafft dann kann ja auch eine neue
wertschöpfung entstehen also nehmen wir
mal das beispiel der automobilindustrie
oder allgemein im mobilitätssektor wenn
man sagt wir investieren zum beispiel in
klimaneutrale kraftstoffe die nicht mehr
auf öl basieren sondern auf sauberem
strom ja dann können wir diese auch in
viele andere länder der welt exportieren
und die dort einen beitrag leisten dass
auch dort die klimaschutz ziele erfüllt
werden und gleichzeitig haben wir hier
neue exportschlager entwickelt und das
muss doch der ansatz sein wenn ich aber
sage in deutschland wird fliegen jetzt
verboten dann wird es dazu führen dass
hier die luftfahrtindustrie kaputt
gemacht wird mit tausenden
arbeitsplätzen man kann ein und andere
länder und andere länder sagen sowie die
in deutschland machen wir das nicht kann
man einfach kontingente festlegen kann
man sagen manche verbote oder manche
regulierungen sind schon deshalb gut
weil sie gerechter sind natürlich gibt
es auch diese möglichkeit und ich finde
es ehrlich gesagt sehr schwierig bin
jetzt von seiner seite argumentiert wird
dass man quasi nur die innovation
braucht weil ganz ehrlich die innovation
hätte man doch auch schon vor zehn
jahren machen können oder vor 15 jahren
haben gerade noch mal gehört seit wann
eigentlich das problem klar es deswegen
wird es kein automatismus geben dass
innovation alles regeln wir brauchen
innovationen ja wir müssen sie
unterstützen ja aber es ist nun mal
nicht so einfach und da muss ich auch
sagen steht ja auch nicht sehr viel mehr
drin in eurem programm als zu sagen wir
setzen auf innovation wir brauchen eine
ein vielschichtiges maßnahmenpaket mit
ordnungspolitischen fragen zum beispiel
ist der verbrenner mutter in vielen
staaten dieser erde schon verboten das
heißt natürlich wird auch diesen frage
auf uns zukommen und wir haben
automobilindustrie die auch das rückgrat
an vielen stellen unserer wirtschaft ist
und dann haben wir seit jahrzehnten ein
protektionismus betrieben der unserer
wirtschaft und auch dem
automobilstandort deutschland schadet
und deswegen ist es unbedingt notwendig
dass politik jetzt auch eine richtung
vorgibt und dann auch sicherheit gibt im
übrigen für investitionen und da muss
ich massiv widersprechen dass ich einmal
ganz kurz einladen weil das ist die
entscheidende frage glaube ich auch bei
der bundestagswahl natürlich müssen wir
die co2 reduktionsziele festlegen als
politik aber der weg wie wir das
erreichen das sollte doch nicht die
politik festlegen ich finde es kann ein
wettbewerb der klimafreundlichen
technologien geben batterie wasserstoff
oder
also die dimension über die wir reden
ist eben die der deutschen einheit da
ist von einer billion euro die rede die
es brauchen wird diese wirtschaft
klimaneutral zu machen das ist wirklich
richtig groß also wenn das alles nur aus
einer innovativen kraft des marktes und
der termin wurde wir wollen ja auch sehr
stark in china investieren wir haben zum
beispiel in dieser legislaturperiode
rekordinvestition für die schiene
beschlossen das ist alles sehr sehr
wichtig natürlich brauchen wir da einen
schwerpunkt darauf das ist völlig klar
und ein anderer wichtiger punkt
natürlich auch dass wir schneller
planung bauen wenn wir 20 jahre für
einen durchschnittlichen projekt in
deutschland benötigen ist das viel zu
lange deswegen haben wir ja auch
vorschläge entwickelt drive als jüngere
abgeordnete dass wir das planungsrecht
reformieren weil wir nicht 20 jahre
warten können bis eine neue schicht und
die sechs monate für das windrad da bin
ich immer neugierig wie das funktioniert
hier schon baarer frage geht natürlich
zu ihnen dieses gespenst von der öko
diktatur macht die runde wird es diesen
umwälzungsprozess ohne gebote und
verbote und ohne harte gesellschaftliche
verteilungskämpfe geben ich glaube das
wird die frage dieser legislaturperiode
also wenn ich herrn plus höre das ist so
friedrich merz die alten evergreens die
wir schon seit 20 jahren kennen so
richtig der klima viel wird nicht so
lange warten bis wir die ganzen
innovationen gemacht haben wir haben
noch die ihren wettlauf und die
dimension zeit würde ich mal nicht ganz
unterschätzen und ich glaube da ist im
bundestag
völlig falsches anreizmodell abgeordnete
werden für vier jahre gewählt das heißt
sie müssen politik machen die sich nach
spätestens vier jahren beim wähler
auszahlt wir kommen ja gleich noch zur
rente aber klassisches beispiel
rentenreform wird vielleicht erst in 10
20 jahren wirksam da kann ich die
früchte dieser legislaturperiode nicht
einsammeln also manchen rentenerhöhung
so csu mäßig und dann gibt es applaus
und fertig also kurzfristiges handeln
wird belohnt von unserem politischen
system das ist ein ganz großes problem
und alle denken noch mit grausen an
gerhard schröder zurück er hat mit der
agenda 2010 mal eine größere form reform
versucht können wir uns im detail
darüber streiten was jetzt sinnvoll war
oder nicht womit ist er belohnt worden
mit seiner abwahl ja das heißt unsere
belohnungs mechanismen in der politik
funktionieren nicht so richtig wie wir
sind einfach zu langsam so und jetzt
haben wir uns ein halbes jahr lang mit
dieser bundestagswahl beschäftigt jetzt
werden wir uns bis hoffentlich nicht
länger als weihnachten mit einer
koalitionsbildung beschäftigen dann muss
sich das neue team erstmal einarbeiten
dann sind die nächsten landtagswahlen da
muss man natürlich rücksicht nehmen und
kann auch nicht wirklich was entscheiden
dh die entscheidende frage und das ist
das verdeckt was der klimawandel uns als
aufgabe mit gibt das ist ein stresstest
für unser politisches system in dem
moment wo wir sehen dass diktaturen oder
autokratien womöglich schnellere
entscheidungen treffen was klimaschutz
angeht werden wir uns irgendwann fragen
müssen kommen wir mit der liberalen
demokratie so wie wir sie hier in
unserem gewissen ich sage dass
entschuldigung nahm artigkeit betreiben
kommen wir an unseren grenzen das heißt
wir müssen sehen dass wir tempo machen
und zwar demokratisches tempo machen und
in dem jetzt immer wieder die
innovations- platte spielen und sagen so
wir fliegen jetzt mit sonnenstrom aus
bayern ein selten so gelacht aber was
heißt es in der übersetzung heißt es
dass wir tatsächlich starts
fordernder und starts gläubiger werden
müssen was wir jetzt in corona zeiten ja
auch schon gelernt haben weil in es nur
mit einem staatlichen dirigismus möglich
sein wird also helmut schmidt hat das ja
mal mit den visionen gesagt dann soll
man zum arzt gehen ich glaube genau das
gegenteil und das war eine der schwächen
der regierung akl die große erzählung
also das was barack obama mit hope in
change damit hat er im wahlkampf
gewonnen das traut sich hier heute
überhaupt keiner mehr die die
neurowissenschaftlerin marina di spricht
von einer vorstellungs krise also wir
haben überhaupt gar nicht mehr die
fähigkeit zu überlegen das ist
vielleicht gar nicht so doof ist das
klima zu schützen siehe krone sie das
ahrtal siehe die brände und alles das
was auf der welt passiert das heißt
klimaschutz ist doch nichts negatives im
sinne von oder das kostet nur geld und
arbeitsplätze sondern das rettet leben
ja wir haben ja noch eine ganz andere
dimension wir müssen ja nicht nur co2
runter kriegen wir müssen ja auch unsere
dämme unsere wiesn unsere die ganze
landschaft umbauen um einigermaßen klima
fest zu sein und zwar relativ schnell ja
und wenn wir jetzt immer wieder die
gleichen debatten führen die wir seit
zehn fünfzehn jahren führen wie kriegen
wir den strom vom wind
irgendwo ins land rein das hatten wir
alles schon und wir sind bei merck und
roche man gleich ist hier respons aus
der runde diese alten lösungen die wir
hatten sind die grundsätzlich hätte
rottmann zu klein für die größe des
problems das es zu lösen gilt also ist
radikal das neue realistisch wie
herr hab ich mal formuliert hat
ja das kann man diskutieren aber wir
auch schon gesagt wurde wir haben es
hier mit einem globalen problem zu tun
und das kann nur funktionieren wenn man
es global angeht und was mir immer
wieder auffällt ist dass es auf die
kommunikation ankommt wir diskutieren
immer nur darüber was kostet es uns die
klimakrise zu bekämpfen wir diskutieren
nie darüber was kostet uns die
klimakrise wenn es mal recht nicht
durchgeht also lassen wir kommen die
schon zu machen es stellt ja genau also
ein wort wie kipp punkte zum beispiel
habe ich im wahlkampf noch nie gehört
warum eigentlich nicht wir haben ein
riesenproblem mit dem golfstrom zum
beispiel wenn das so weitergeht warum
hat da kein spitzenkandidat bisher
wirklich mal darüber gesprochen und
gesagt wie er das problem angehen will
mir kommt es manchmal ein bisschen so
vor wie bei unseren kindern ich habe
zwei kleine töchter wenn ich den tag du
darfst nicht süßes essen ihnen aber
nicht erklärt warum nicht dann sagen sie
nur ich will aber trotzdem wenn ich ihn
sagt duda die süßes essen weil wenn du
zu viel davon ist dann kriegst du
schlechte zähne und dann tut es dir weh
dann verstehen die das und deshalb finde
ich wir sollten viel mehr über diesen
punkt sprechen und ich glaube gerade so
was wir das was wir jetzt in diesem
sommer erlebt haben mit den mit dem
hochwasser das war schon für viele ein
augenöffner und ich hoffe dass wir diese
katastrophen in der form so schnell
nicht wieder erleben aber das kann man
natürlich auch nutzen davon ausgehend
die folgen zu skizzieren und zu sagen es
wird noch viel teurer wenn wir jetzt
nichts machen und das was uns jetzt
bevorsteht an maßnahmen das ist das
kleinere übel im gegensatz zu dem was in
zwanzig dreißig oder vierzig jahren
passieren würde wenn euch das ist ein
ziemlicher frontalangriff wenn er sagt
wir reden viel zu wenig über die
probleme die mangelnder klimaschutz also
keinen klimaschutz bedeuten würde für
die menschheit das ist vorwurf nummer
eins und der nummer zwei ist dem wähler
wird eigentlich nicht die wahrheit
gesagt wir gucken nur auf die nächsten
vier jahre argument von heiko schröder
von von gesprächen mit obama so weit ist
es noch nicht man
sondern sollten gut beraten auf 8 und
eine zehn jahres perspektive schauen was
ja jungpolitikerin ja ich würde total
zustimmen aber ich glaube auch dass es
nicht nur darum gehen sollte dann zu
sagen was ist in fünf oder in zehn
jahren alles schlecht sondern ich glaube
das was uns fehlt es zu sagen was könnte
auch alles wirklich gut werden in den
nächsten jahren und ich finde dass die
klimaschutzdebatte und das merken wir ja
auch und das merkt man auch wenn man bei
der grünen jugend ist oder wenn man bei
den grünen ist dass viele leute immer
noch vorbehalte gegenüber klimaschutz
haben den es auch in zukunft besser
gehen könnte wenn wir in keine ahnung in
einer gesellschaft leben in der die
städte schöner sind wohl jeder gut von a
nach b kommt ohne viel geld dafür zu
bezahlen wo die energie günstig ist also
da können ganz viele gute sachen können
auf diesem weg passieren und ich glaube
das kriegen wir eigentlich nicht erzählt
war jetzt muss man halt dann sich da
drum herum drücken und es kann halt auch
unsozialen klimaschutz geben ich kann
verstehen warum menschen davor angst
haben der co2 preis ist ja jetzt gerade
auch nicht richtig sozial ausgeglichen
aber das liegt ja auch daran dass die
cdu da jetzt nicht so lust darauf hatte
an der stelle klar haben leute
vorbehalte dagegen ihr leben könnte ja
auch schlechter werden und es ist
natürlich schwierig wenn ich dann zu
hause keine ahnung zu meiner mutter in
die alte umgebung fahre da verdienen die
leute nicht viel und wenn ich den jetzt
sage ja also du bist schon im
niedriglohnsektor aber jetzt verzichtet
mal auf alles weil sonst wird alles ganz
schlimm für die ganze welt das ist ne
scheiße das ist eine schlechte erzählung
das ist also ich glaube das bringt uns
nicht weiter entweder beschaffen
klimaschutz mit den menschen die gerade
arbeiten oder wir schaffen ihn hat nicht
wie es die grünen wollen wird so für
alle nur teurer gerade wenn man mal das
beispiel nehmen seine pflege kraft die
im ländlichen raum wohnt mit dem auto
zur frühschicht fahren muss ins
krankenhaus oder auf die pflegestationen
die ist aufs auto angewiesen jetzt
vielleicht vor zwei drei oder vier
jahren neuen benziner neuen diese
gekauft der kann ich doch nicht erzählen
die soll sich jetzt in zwei drei jahren
neues elektroauto kaufen deswegen muss
ich für diese menschen doch eine lösung
finden dass ich sagt die kern der arten
kann das auto klimaneutral werden und da
kommen wir wieder zum beispiel dann auf
klimaneutrale kraftstoffe zurück gegen
die sich die grünen sperren und das wird
ansonsten schwere soziale folgen für das
land haben und es aber wir müssen
klimaschutz immer aus sozial ausgewogen
gestalten ja ich finde es wirklich gut
ist und was sagt und ich glaube wir
können uns voll darauf einigen und dann
zum beispiel dafür sorgen dass direkt in
den ersten 100 tagen der nächsten
regierung der mindestlohn angehoben wird
oder die pflegekräfte mehr verdienen
damit es ihnen einfach besser geht aber
ich glaube da werdet ihr vielleicht dann
wieder nicht an bord und ich finde es
ehrlich gesagt auch als person die
selbst aus verhältnissen kommt immer ein
bisschen schwierig dass ihr immer dann
sagt ihr seid für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit wenn es um so was geht und
zu der pflege wie pflegekräfte sind so
stark gestiegen in dieser
legislaturperiode wie noch nie und die
arbeitsbedingungen sind immer noch
ziemlich ziemlich teilweise ausgebessert
aber noch mal mit ein weiter pass ist
über die menschen im ländlichen raum
reden die in die städte müssen natürlich
haben die ein auto und dann gibt es da
mittel wie keine ahnung die
pendlerpauschalen da gibt es zum
beispiel wir sagen wir müssen den wir
müssen den co2 preis sozial ausgleichen
das heißt das geld was durch den co2
preis mediation husum solle gezeigt
werden dass die menschen die eben nicht
diesen häuser vier autos und fünf flüge
in die usa haben fünf business flüge in
die usa kriegen eigentlich mehr geld
dadurch zurück und ich glaube das wisst
ihr auch von dem konzept ja aber es geht
natürlich nicht nur darum es geht auf
der einen seite darum diese maßnahmen
auszugleichen aber es geht darum dass es
den menschen generell besser gehen muss
in unserer kleinen aber mit
oder eben nicht in der art und weise
bekämpfen und dafür sorgen dass es
bessere arbeitsbedingungen gibt und
höhere löhne nicht nur für die pfleger
in sondern für die vielen anderen
menschen die auch dann dort wohnen und
das ist halt einfach jede menge denn in
den letzten jahren unter cdu regierung
sehr stark gestiegen ja und sie sind
immer noch arbeitet jede fünfte person
im niedriglohnsektor so wir reden gleich
nochmal über die sozial natürlich die
sozialen frage ich wollte auf dieses
beispiel von hajo schumacher mit der
rente noch mal kommen und mit der
ehrlichkeit der politiker haben sie sich
nicht genauso darüber geärgert jetzt
gesagt zu bekommen dass wir mit den
doppelten haltelinien von der spd und
andrea nahles die 48 prozent bei der
rente halten werden für die leute wie
realistisch ist es für jemanden wie sie
ja ich hatte noch so viel zum thema
wollte jetzt aber auf den realismus auf
den realismus kommen und auf die
möglichkeit tatsächlich reformen zu
wagen die dann so groß sind dass sie die
politiker erst mal vom feld schicken
also wir haben ich finde bei in vielen
bereichen und gerade auch beim thema
rente eine situation wo ebenso getan
wird eigentlich schließlich das schön an
andy ihrer merkel war so getan wird als
könne alles bleiben wie es ist wenn man
einfach nichts macht und das stimmt
nicht weil die welt entwickelt sich
weiter die demographie die sitzt uns im
nacken bis 20.25 da gehen die babyboomer
in rente dann haben wir dann haben wir
auch so eine art kipp punkt könnte man
vielleicht sagen und dann haben wir ein
massives problem dass wir ehrlich gesagt
ja heute schon haben also auch heute
funktioniert unser umlagefinanziert das
system den milliarden bis 100 milliarden
euro also das ist ein fünftel
mittlerweile vor der korona krise ein
viertel des bundeshaushaltes in ein
rentensystem fließt was ich eigentlich
selber finanzieren soll also das ist
wahnsinn und da einfach zu sagen wir
machen jetzt so weiter die renten sind
sicher norbert blüm ja eigentlich jetzt
urlaub scholz ohne etwas dafür zu tun
ohne über zu überlegen können wir
vielleicht das ja der vorschlag den wir
machen einen teil auf eine
kapitaldeckung umstellen damit auch
menschen wirklich das eigentum an ihrer
rente zu verschaffen und nicht nur in
anspruch der nämlich auch davon abhängt
wie groß werden eigentlich die nächsten
generation also da haben wir auch
massive soziale gedanke gewonnen hajo
schumacher war ja eigentlich wissen alle
dass das nicht funktionieren kann und
jetzt frage ich mal ein plus hier nach
rechts außen nur geografisch
eigentlich wissen alle dass das nicht
mehr reichen wird für sie werden diese
48 prozent ihres einkommens sicherlich
nicht zu halten sein wenn man nichts an
unserem jetzigen system ändert das ja
schon ein subventionssystem ist wann
kommt ehrlichkeit in eine solche politik
das ist ja so offensichtlich ist auch
nicht so ein super neues thema sondern
es ist seit jahrzehnten diskutiert und
alle sagen geht reicht dann das haben
wir nicht wir passen ja auch gerade
schon die lebensarbeitszeit an bis ende
dieses jahrzehnts und das ist auch sehr
notwendig weil die menschen die ein
bisschen richtig das war tatsächlich ein
gemeinsamer erfolg auch der großen
koalition zu beginn der ersten
regierungsjahre von angela merkel dass
man gesagt hat man leitet diese
rentenreform ein die ja immer noch auch
anhalten und die notwendig sind weil
wenn alle immer älter werden und immer
länger gesund bleiben dann ist es ja
notwendig dass man auch etwas länger
einzahlen muss wobei für uns auch immer
einen punkt ganz wichtig war und ist das
nicht die berufe in den hart körperlich
gearbeitet wird dass da jemand zum
beispiel mit 70 dann auch auf dem bau
schwere sachen schleppen muss oder sie
werden also mir bringt arbeit sehr viel
spaß ich glaube auch dass wir uns dass
wir uns dass wir uns auch da in der
debatte etwas anders aufstellen müssen
arbeit wird häufig mit etwas negativem
verbunden und einige gerade die spd
wirkt immer den eindruck man müsste am
liebsten die arbeit los werden und dann
hat man es ein schönes leben ich glaube
arbeit bedeutet teilhabe und ich glaube
auch dass viele menschen sich eine viel
stärkere flexibilisierung wünschen also
die zeiten in denen jemand 40 jahre oder
45 jahre durchgehend gearbeitet hat
vollzeit dann in rente ging dann nichts
mehr gemacht hat die sind vorbei ich
glaube viele 70-jährige frischen
hinsicht jährige die können und die
wollen auch arbeiten und das sollte man
dann politisch noch mal anders man
könnte sich vor heinrich über die rente
doch genauso aufregend wie über die über
klima man könnte doch sagen ich weiß
sowieso dass ich keine mehr kriegen
werde das ist fatalismus man könnte aber
auch sagen freitag demonstrieren wir für
den klimaschutz und am donnerstag für
die rente warum tut es die jugend nicht
warum tun dass junge leute nicht also
ich glaube schon dass es mit der rente
voll das drängende thema ist aber
ehrlich gesagt nicht nur für die jungen
leute sondern auch für die vielen
älteren leute die gerade keine gute
rente bekomme ich frag einen sogar ihrem
rund ich würde sagen dass es also ich
würde einfach sagen das ist wirklich
eine lehrstelle ist also wir haben
einfach für ganz viele soziale themen
nicht in der selben art und weise eine
soziale massenbewegung auf den straßen
wie es bei file is for future haben ich
würde mir auch keine ahnung weit ist
gegen kinderarmut gerade auf den straßen
wünschen und strengt sich natürlich an
und man kommt mit bewegung in kontakt
aber ich glaube das liegt sehr viel
daran dass wir in den letzten jahren
auch gerade auch in den letzten 16
jahren sehr viel darüber geredet haben
das soziale fragen da muss jeder einfach
irgendwie für sich selber gucken wie er
klar kommt jeder ist seines eigenen
glückes schmied und wenn man komplett
selbst für sich da nur verantwortlich
ist wenn es nur ein persönliches problem
davon ist dass man nicht hart genug
gearbeitet hat dann ist das ja auch
nichts für das man demonstrieren geben
muss am ende des tages also ich würde
ich würde sagen dass das dazu geführt
hat zum thema die politisierung oder wie
man nochmal über politische fragen
geredet hat dass die soziale frage erst
über die letzten jahre wieder mehr in
den mittelpunkt von der politischen
debatte gerückt ist und ich glaube es
ist gut darüber zu reden wie es eine
sichere rente geben kann und wie es auch
reformen gehen kann aber ich glaube
nicht unbedingt dass es ein
generationenkonflikt heimische markt
noch mal den finger
da sind wir wieder im großen weiten feld
der psychologie bill clinton die älteren
erinnern sich hatte in seiner
erfolgreichen zeit als präsident ein
ganz interessantes prinzip das hießt
revelation also dreieck und da wurde
versucht dass man bestimmte themen die
vielleicht gar nicht was miteinander zu
tun haben trotzdem zusammen bekommt nur
als idee wenn wir älteren wüssten dass
jedes windrad was sich in deutschland
dreht vielleicht zwei prozent seines
ertrages in einen rentenfonds
produziert an strom dann wäre auch die
akzeptanz von windrädern vielleicht ein
bisschen höher zweites beispiel wir
reden gerade hier in berlin über die
enteignung von wohnungsbestand vor
vielen jahren der kanzler hieß noch
helmut kohl wurden sehr sehr viele
wohnungen aus öffentlich finanzierten
mitteln also von steuergeldern bezahlt
hier in berlin oder auch bundesweit
wurden an private unternehmen
auf die jetzt an der börse sind damit
geld verdienen kann man machen ja hätte
hätte fahrradkette hätten wir damals
diesen wohnungsbestand viele
hunderttausend wohnungen öffentlich
gefördert in einen immobilienfonds
gepackt und daraus unsere renten
langfristig bezahlt aus den mieten dann
hätten wir das wohnungsproblem also wir
hätten das irgendwie genossenschaftlich
einigermaßen ordentlich verwaltet und
wir hätten einen zuschuss für die rente
man kann solche sachen machen das ist
durchaus möglich man muss sie sich nur
mal wagen zu denken das ist alles nicht
so schwierig
sachen widersprechen
das ist ein bisschen schade finde dass
wir über wählerinnen und wähler immer so
ein bisschen sprechen als ob die selber
nicht ablegen könnten und sich von der
politik nicht einfach bestimmte dinge
wünschen alleine wenn ich jetzt die
argumentationslinien von meiner rechten
mir anhöre dann geht es immer wieder um
angst dann geht es immer wieder darum
dass man irgendwie sagt man kann den weg
zur arbeit nicht mehr zu nicht mehr
bezahlen die renten sind nicht mehr
sicher das sind glaube ich alles
argumentationslinien dienen uns nicht
für politik begeistern lassen sondern
ich möchte gerne darüber sprechen wie
können wir auch positiv und das hat
sarahs nicht gerade auch genau richtig
gesagt beschreiben wo unser land in 20
jahren steht das wünsche ich mir für die
ära nach merkel und deswegen würde ich
auch noch mal gerne klarstellen dass es
nicht so ist dass zum beispiel die spd
sagt dass das rentensystem einfach so
weiterlaufen soll aber wir sagen die
gesetzliche rente ist das fundament und
wird am ende für die gerechtigkeit im
alter sorgen die wir brauchen wenn wir
im niedrigen niedriglohnsektor
austrocknen das heißt
mindestlohn von 12 euro einführen wenn
wir auch mal über frauen erwerbsarbeit
sprechen werden ja immer wieder auch
skandinavische länder angeführt ja da
ist die frauenerwerbsquote viel viel
höher frauen sind diejenigen die im
niedriglohnsektor arbeit die minijobs
haben wir haben eine zunahme von mini
jobs als zweitjob in den letzten 16
jahren gehabt noch und nöcher deshalb
finde ich es auch wirklich falsch wie du
hier über arbeit gesprochen hast es gibt
so viele menschen in diesem land die
sicher auch gerne zur arbeit gehen
würden aber einfach ein extrem niedrigen
lohn bekommen und sich fragen warum sie
eigentlich jeden morgen aufstehen weil
sie danach nämlich noch aufstocken gehen
aufstocken müssen und deswegen wenn wir
über rente sprechen sprechen ja auch
über lohnpolitik und dann sprechen wir
auch darüber dass wir diese gesetzliche
rente so stärken müssen und ist es
richtig auch aus junger perspektive zu
sagen dass die gesetzliche rente das
fundament ist und sie ja auch noch für
meine generation geht werden wir das
ding stabilisieren wenn alle das gefühl
haben ich muss irgendwie selber
klarkommen und investieren übrigens die
hälfte der bevölkerung hat kein vermögen
dann frage ich mich wie wir dieses
system aufrechterhalten wollen
solidargedanken
wir müssen uns doch auch mal anschauen
dass wir in deutschland ein also der
größte haushaltsposten geht ans arbeits
und sozialministerium 100 milliarden in
die rente viele sozialleistungen die wir
zahlen und warum das unser land dann
trotzdem nicht gerecht also wir müssen
noch mal schauen einerseits muss das
alles irgendwo herkommen wir brauchen
eine gute wirtschaft das die grundlage
für all das weil wir all das sonst nicht
bezahlen können und auf der anderen
seite
ist bildung doch die grundlage auch
dafür dass man ein gutes leben haben
kann und warum wird da nicht viel mehr
auch darüber gesprochen bildung kam
jetzt hier noch gar nicht auf obwohl wir
über generationengerechtigkeit
aussprechen das ist doch der schlüssel
auch dafür im leben zu haben eine
aufstiegs das aufstiegsversprechen was
er unserer sozialen marktwirtschaft
eigentlich innewohnt dass man das wieder
leben kann dass man auch eben in dem job
aussteigen kann dass man auch vielleicht
noch meine weiterbildung macht dass man
nochmal was anderes macht im leben das
ist auch die grundlage für all das und
da wir sprechen immer nur darüber
irgendwie höhere höhere sozialleistungen
hier höhere sozialleistungen da höhere
renten aber darüber dass man sich das
selber erarbeiten kann und dass man die
chance dazu den menschen geholfen haben
das uns einmal
offen eingehen weil es bei der spd und
bei den grünen hat man wie so eine
vorstellung da sind ganz viele jobs da
und man schafft als staat immer mehr
jobs das ist der völlig falsche ansatz
und das hat in der geschichte noch nie
funktioniert sondern erst die jobs die
jobs müssen auch eine schande werden von
unternehmen und von unternehmern und
wenn zb spd grüne und linkspartei in
einem hochsteuerland deutschland in dem
land in dem wir die höchsten steuern und
sozialabgaben haben jetzt auch noch über
weitere steuererhöhungen nachdenken und
über die einführung neue substanz
steuern nachdenken wie zum beispiel die
vermögenssteuer wenn entzieht man ganz
vielen mittelständischen unternehmen
auch teilweise kleinunternehmer
natürlich auch größeren unternehmen
kapitalkraft war eine substanz steuer
eingeführt wird die die unternehmen
nicht mehr in die lage versetzt zu
investieren und dadurch jobs zu schaffen
und wir werden nur an und die beste
beste dreimal bei der ausreden lassen
die bessere rentenpolitik ist immer auch
eine gute wirtschaftspolitik weil nur so
und ines martinez könnte den herbst
natürlich auch noch mal sagen ob es
nicht tatsächlich ganz schlau wäre die
löhne zu erhöhen in diesem land erstens
weil die arbeit dadurch natürlich mehr
wert würde und auf der anderen seite wie
auch gleich noch soziale
sicherungssysteme anders bedienen würde
bei denen der mindestlohn so ein drama
für die wirtschaft ein kleiner mann hat
man hat ganz bewusst entschieden das war
eigentlich auch immer eine vereinbarung
zwischen spd und cdu dass das keine
politische entscheidung ist sondern eine
vereinbarung zwischen gewerkschaften und
arbeitgebern mussten hatte man immer
steigern das hat man immerhin hat man
die geschäftsordnung war und dieses
versprechen wird nun braucht vielleicht
können wir einer das klingt das klingt
immer gut dass man einfach sagt ja der
eine sagt 14 euro der andere sagt 15
euro lohn der nächste sagt 18 euro lohn
aber die löhne müssen ja irgendwie auch
finanziert werden und das heißt wenn
irgendwann diese löhne nicht mehr
finanziert werden können dann gehen
entweder arbeitsplätze verloren oder
unternehmen sind nicht mehr wettbewerb
gewinnen natürlich ist in meinen augen
wird aber es war nämlich mal jähren sich
doch überlegen sich doch ob sie nach
deutschland gehen oder ob sie in andere
länder gehen stimmt aber es war schwer
denn in der steuerpolitik dann wird das
dazu führen dass viele arbeitsplätze
verloren gehen bis jetzt ist das
gegenteil der fall für junge menschen
gerade also ich wollte einmal kurz mal
wieder was du zu jungen menschen sagen
weil wir jetzt ganz gut über so
gerechtigkeit wenig wird erst mal sagen
gerade wenn wir nicht so viel geld für
die sozialsysteme ausgeben wollen
brauchen wir höhere löhne aber was ist
führt gerade für eine aussicht sechs
wenn die menschen durch dieses
bildungssystem und die adu weist bin
voll bei der wir brauchen ein besseres
bildungssystem da muss mehr geld rein
das muss besser aufgestellt sein man
muss auch mal darüber nachdenken ob
diese art von dreiteilung so früh schon
sinn macht aber selbst wenn alle mit
einem abi durch dieses bildungssystem
gerade durchgehend meine generation die
menschen die gerade sind ich bin 20
20 cent gehen jetzt durchs gymnasium
machen bachelor machen master stehen sie
am ende auf dem arbeitsmarkt und ein
fünftel von ihnen muss in den
niedriglohnsektor weil es einfach weil
das der arbeitsmarkt ist und was ist das
denn gerade für eine aussicht für junge
menschen am ende auf dem arbeitsmarkt zu
lernen voraussetzungen für gute lehre
aber schön wenn google habe aber gute
arbeitsplätze sind die beste
voraussetzung denn was bringt mir der
doktor wenn ich dann trotzdem muss ja
und eigentlich war schnell dazu sagen
heinrich ist das beste beispiel dafür
eigentlich dass man nicht die reichen
eltern braucht die mama war
alleinerziehend mit hartz4 groß geworden
studium geschafft jetzt in köln also
gleich geschafft und natürlich auf
abitur gemacht und um diese dinge sehr
gekämpft und wenn sie so engagiert
darüber sprechen dann hat man erst recht
das gefühl man bekommt es noch nicht in
den schoß gelegt in diesem land ja ich
würde also ich freue mich dass ich in
der situation bin in der ich bin dass
ich auch gerade nicht in hartz 4 leben
das ich gerade nicht in armut lebe aber
ich würde nicht sagen dass ich mich da
hoch oder herausgearbeitet habe weil
naja ganz viel davon hatte einfach mit
zufall zu tun ganz viele junge menschen
also selbst leute die mit mir in einer
klasse war die haben dann halt einfach
nicht die gymnasialempfehlung bekommen
sondern dem wort gesagt gesamtschule
oder hauptschule das wird eh nichts mit
dir die sind gar nicht erst aus
gymnasium gekommen sie hatten vielleicht
keine ahnung die sie hätten vielleicht
nach hilfe gebraucht hätten die gar
nicht bezahlt bekommen und haben
deswegen kein gutes abitur oder gar kein
abitur geschrieben sind früher
abgegangen und ich finde das hat alles
nichts mit können also das hat nichts
mit so können zu tun und auch von
kindern zu verlangen dass sie sich aus
armut raus arbeiten müssen finde ich
sowieso schon total schon mal sowas ist
die forderung die forderung ist
eigentlich reiche eltern für alle
absolut also ich würde jetzt einmal ganz
kurz die jungen menschen beruhigen
wollen wenn wir boomer wir sind nämlich
ganz schön viele ich bin der geburten
stärkste jahrgang 64 wir sind 1,3
millionen wenn wir alle in dieser rente
sind die wir dann nicht mehr kriegen
dann wird die nachfolgende generation er
einen arbeitsmarkt vorfinden der leute
sucht also arbeitslosigkeit wird in eure
generation vermutlich kein riesengroßes
thema was ein anderes thema wird und da
sind wir beim thema soziale
gerechtigkeit es gibt zwei worten auch
in eurer generation die einen erben die
wachsen also praktisch mit einem
goldenen löffel in verschiedenen
körperöffnungen auch wer die brauchen
eigentlich gar nicht mehr zu arbeiten
weil sie halt 23 mietshäuser haben so
und die anderen die nicht erben die
haben natürlich jetzt in dieser zeit
auch gerade wenn man nicht viel verdient
überhaupt keine chance irgendwelches
kapital anzusparen oder meine wohnung zu
kaufen oder so diese klassischen
aufstands und wohlstands versprechen die
werden den wirtschaftswunderjahren haben
und insofern geht die soziale schere
auseinander noch weiter auseinander und
entschuldigung herr plus natürlich kann
man damit steuern was machen wenn wir
100 milliarden mindestens 100 milliarden
an verstecktem capital war gerade erst
wieder eine studie im ausland haben ja
dann kann man da sehr wohl was besteuern
und wenn zb die großen digital konzerne
in europa oder weltweit sogar ihre
milliarde dämpfer dienste wir reden
nicht von umsätzen wir reden von
gewinnen so kunstvoll verstecken dass
sie am ende 0,08 prozent in irland
bezahlen dann haben wir ein problem
und das sind nicht arbeitsplätze die uns
verschwunden gehen das sind irgendwelche
jungs die es lustig finden mit
irgendwelchen gerätschaften ins weltall
zu fliegen da ist das geld ja und da
kann man auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen was holen und diese diese ewige
platte aus steuern sind böse nein sind
sie nicht haben weil
aber immer frieden aber in hessen hat
hier aber ich habe nicht gesagt steuern
sind böse das hat glaube ich ja auch
niemand in der runde behauptet so sagt
wenn wir einer mittelschweren in einem
land in dem wir die höchsten steuern und
sozialabgaben von allen oecd staaten
haben das heißt der staat hat auch kein
einnahmeproblem
und was sie gesagt haben schumacher ist
ja eher ein plädoyer für die
erbschaftsteuer dann kann man darüber
reden dass man sagt eine niedrige
gerechte erbschaftssteuer für alle da
würde ich auch mit gehen ich habe aber
sinnlos weiß ich aber schon jetzt schon
mal wenn sie möglicherweise einmal
aussprechen das super ich habe eben aber
über die vermögenssteuer gesprochen dass
eine substanz steuer die müssen alle
unternehmen dann im land zahl derjenigen
die noch nicht in die gewinnzone
zurückgekehrt sind und wie man noch
während der korona krise so etwas
vorschlagen kann in einem land in dem es
eh so viele steuern gibt das finde ich
ist
wir merken uns aber das ist wirklich
interessant dass sie das türchen öffnen
würden und sagen zu erben in einer
gesellschaft die eigentlich eine
leistungsgesellschaft ist und so groß
und vermögen zu erben ist eigentlich
nicht fährt dann müsste die mich darin
uns also ich bin sehr der meinung dass
wir den sozialstaat in gewisser weise
neu denken müssen wir brauchen mehr
investitionen in frühkindliche bildung
damit wir eben da ungerechtigkeiten
abbauen also bildung und
chancengerechtigkeit darf nicht abhängig
vom einkommen der eltern dass oder von
der herkommt genau was immer noch so ist
deswegen bin ich da sehr engagiert dabei
aber ich glaube nicht dass wir am ende
eine gerechtere gesellschaft schaffen
indem er einfach immer mehr steuern
erhöht und neue steuern einführen aber
sondern wir müssen da bricht normal
andreas schröder an angriffen wir müssen
glaube ich da an einigen bereichen nur
denken wenn wir jetzt schon ein drittel
der gesamten volkswirtschaft leistungen
für soziales ausgeben da muss man doch
ehrlicherweise sagen und immer noch
viele probleme da sind das wird nicht
immer zielgenau investiert und da muss
ich mir noch gedanken machen soll ich
vielleicht etwas mehr geld in
frühkindliche bildung stecken damit alle
gerade jüngeren und auch gute chancen
versuchen wir noch mal die frage ein
bisschen größer zu stellen sie findet
auch ein bisschen größer gestellt in
diesem wahlkampf statt indem nämlich vor
einem rot rot grünen
regierungswechsel gewarnt wird oder
rot-grün-roten regierungswechsel
gefahren wird die herzlos festhalten
sich ausgerechnet diese beiden frauen
hier vorstellen könnten und auch keine
angst davor hätten sie sagen alle
bürgerlichkeit deutschlands muss jetzt
auf den plan weil rot grün rot darf es
nicht geben frage an sie beide wäre es
denn tatsächlich schlimm wenn
empfinden sie sich noch als bürgerlich
sind sie bürgerlich wenn sie für rot
grün roten ich verstehe auch wirklich
ehrlich gesagt also ich weiß nicht ob
das so politik sprechen ist den ich
nicht so ganz verstanden habe als ich
ins suche und reingekommen bin aber ich
verstehe nicht christi definition von
bürgerlicher sein soll also sind
bürgerlich sollen dann manchmal seien es
irgendwie sonst der kleine mann sein
manchmal sonst irgendwie die arbeiter
innen seien manchmal sonst an die
menschen vom dorf seien dann sonst nie
dann sonst doch die menschen im
prenzlauer berg sein die viel geld also
ich hab keine ahnung was das bedeutet
ehrlich gesagt ich finde das ist eine
worthülse ich bin der rot rot grün ist
eine gute aussicht weil wir da gerade
drei parteien haben die gerade im
bereich von sozialer gerechtigkeit
sehr viele gemeinsame projekte haben die
der mehrheit der bevölkerung wirklich
gut tun könnte und ehrlich gesagt diese
rot rot grün debatte und diese angst die
da gerade geschürt wird wenn ich mir
also ich meine es auch jetzt nicht
persönlich gegen dich oder sie aber wenn
ich jetzt nur mit jungen menschen
geredet habe so bei mir als ich noch zur
schule gegangen bin oder jetzt mit den
leuten also die haben erden problem
damit wenn sich andere parteien nicht
genug von der cdu abgrenzen und nicht
wenn sie sich nicht genug von der
linkspartei ab rosenthal müssen wir
gleich nochmal ländlichen milieus
unterwegs gleich nochmal nach der
vergangenheit von olaf scholz fragen
also nicht nur dass olaf scholz
natürlich die agenda 2010 mit erfunden
hat und übrigens damit natürlich auch
für diesen niedriglohnsektor mit
zuständig war er hat eine lustige
historie als juso chef weil er das sagte
zum beispiel
die überwindung der kapitalistischen
ökonomie muss zu den zielsetzungen der
sozialdemokratie zählen
so sehen sie in ihren kanzlerkandidaten
noch so ein kleines fünkchen anti
kapitalismus glimmen glauben sie dass es
das noch gibt bei olaf scholz also
nochmal die überwindung der
kapitalistischen ökonomie muss
zielsetzung der sozialdemokratie sein
naja wenn man den bild dem bild glaubt
was derzeit aus meiner sicht doch recht
panisch auch gerade von seiten der cdu
aufgebaut wird dann wird er der nächste
anführer eines antikapitalistischen
bündnisses und genau diese polemik und
zuspitzung lehne ich ab ich glaube wir
müssen zeit angucken wo gibt es
gemeinsamkeiten und wo können wir
wirklich etwas erreichen in der frage
investieren in das land in der frage
klimawandel in der frage in bildung auch
geld stecken relief ist in diesem
bündnis und das da sehe ich einfach
schon schnittmengen mit auch der
linkspartei vor allem mit den grünen
natürlich also wenn es für rot grün
reicht freue ich mich sehr aber
natürlich auch mit der linkspartei und
deswegen saskia esken kevin kühnert das
sagen viele das sind dann die die das
regiment übernehmen werden und olaf
scholz wird ein also ich bitte alle
wählerinnen und wähler und alle
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
sich wirklich von dieser polemik jetzt
nicht ablenken dass ablenken zu lassen
wir haben zukunftsprogramm beschlossen
und in diesen zukunftsprogramm steht
drin dass wir machen wollen und wer olaf
scholz kennt in den letzten jahren und
jetzt hin konnte man ihn ja ob ich gut
kennenlernen der weiß auch genau wofür
steht und deswegen können wir bitte über
inhalte sprechen wir können darüber
sprechen welche prinzipien müssen gelten
aber nicht diese polier schröder hat von
einem harten drops gesprochen wenn die
fdp zusammen mit der sozialdemokratie
und den grünen regieren würde also so
eine vorstellung saskia esken und
christian lindner in einer regierung das
ist dann dieser harte drops oder schon
eine ganze tüte voller harter drops also
ich hätte ja auch jessica und sarah sehr
aber wenn ich mir das so anhöre dann
sehe ich da schon auch große
unterschiede also auch in der frage wer
soll eigentlich investieren zum beispiel
ist das der start der erst sehr viele
steuern einsammelt und dann entscheidet
wo wird es jetzt gerade am besten
gebraucht das funktioniert in der
sozialpolitik schon mal nicht so gut in
der vergangenheit oder sind es die
unternehmen die die freiräume haben auch
zu investieren die natürlich klare
rahmenbedingungen bekommen aber dann
auch die möglichkeit auch diese großen
herausforderungen die werden der
klimawandel der winter nicht vom staat
alleine bekämpft sondern die großen
emissionen die sind bei den unternehmen
und deswegen brauchen die auch die
freiräume das investieren und ich sehe
so zu sagen da grundlegend
unterschiedliche ansätze wer eigentlich
wie viel verantwortung trägt wer wen wir
auch verantwortung zu trauern ich glaube
wir können den menschen wir können den
unternehmen in unserem land mehr
zutrauen als spd und grüne das tun und
deswegen sehe ich da also halte ich das
für eine große herausforderung wenn man
sich vorstellt dann eine koalition von
heinrich ist genauso interessant ihre
parteispitze annalena baerbock herr beck
sie haben sich sehr distanziert von den
grünen gehalten von den linken nicht
allen schulen
sich selbst
glauben sie denn dass man mit herrn plus
zusammen und zusammen mit frau schröder
in regierungsverhandlungen treten können
wir würden dann von jamaika reden das
war mal gar nicht so ein fernes ländchen
also also für uns als grüne jugend ist
klar regieren dann wenn sich wirklich
was verändert und für uns ist klar dass
es muss wohl im klimaschutz vorangehen
als auch im bett in dem leben der
menschen das heißt die menschen soll es
besser gehen wo einem sozial besser und
ja auch so sehr ich dich auch persönlich
schätze wir haben da glauben also die
unsere beiden parteien haben da glaube
ich in der unterschiedliche dinge
darunter wir wollen dass also da würde
ich vermutlich wird auch nicht mal nur
sagen also ich glaube es geht nicht nur
darum zu fragen wer jetzt investiert
oder wer wem was zutraut uns geht es
eher darum zu sagen wir wollen zum
beispiel nicht dass bürger innen dafür
dadurch dass sie dann horrende preise
für dinge bezahlen dafür bestraft werden
das unternehmen hat weiter naja das
klima zwischen höheren dadurch dass sie
weiter eben co2 in die luft blasen und
ich finde eben schon und ich finde eben
schon das klar sein muss dass gerade
grüne die auch immer wieder in der
kritik dafür stehen bauer ist voll die
unsoziale partei ich möchte nicht dass
es eine regierungsbeteiligung gibt in
der es den menschen am ende schlechter
geht der ist vor allem den menschen am
ende sozial schlechter geht es sollte
kein co2 preis ohne ausgleich geben es
braucht endlich höhere löhne und da gibt
es parteien mit denen das
wahrscheinlicher ist umzusetzen und
parteien mit denen es unwahrscheinlicher
ist umzusetzen
deswegen halten wir da die ansprüche
hoch und gucken dann was passiert nach
der wahl
möglich man nochmal aus düsseldorf dazu
gebeten wenn sie eben diesen wahlkampf
schauen haben sie das gefühl dass die
themen der jungen leute da genug eine
rolle spielen hätten sie erwartet dass
es noch mal so einen lagerwahlkampf gibt
das zugegebenermaßen nicht also es hat
sich ja jetzt dann doch in den letzten
wochen zugespitzt ich vermute mal stark
durch den erfolg den die spd gerade in
den umfragen einfährt aber ich rufe die
ganze zeit schon so ein bisschen unruhig
auf seinem stuhl hin und her weil wir
sprechen jetzt schon wieder über politik
allgemein und nicht so sehr um die die
zukunft auch die zukunft der jungen
menschen und ich sehe eine ganz große
gefahr ich habe viel kontakt zu jungen
menschen über meine youtube kanäle und
die melden sich immer wieder und
schreiben mir acht die politiker mir ist
völlig egal wen ich wähle es passiert
nichts und es kommt eh nichts bei rum
also ein typisches stammtischparolen und
das kommt aber nicht nur von leuten die
man auch am stammtisch vermuten würde
würde sondern es kommt tatsächlich aus
der mitte der gesellschaft und wir vorne
über rente gesprochen es gab kürzlich
eine insa umfrage bei der 50 prozent der
über der unter 40 jährigen gesagt haben
ich bekomme wahrscheinlich später keine
rente keine gesetzliche rente und das
zeigt für mich ein starkes misstrauen in
den start starkes misstrauen in die
politik und so ein gefühl von die können
sowieso nichts für mich machen und das
zeigt sich auch gerade bei jungen leuten
und ich finde das ist eine große gefahr
dann wenn wir die verlieren dann
verlieren wir irgendwann auch die
demokratie und siegesstimmung zu gefragt
hatte ich natürlich genau nach den
jungen leuten warum sie sich eben dann
nicht auch für diese sozialen dinge
engagieren das wäre ja genau möglich
also dass sagen sie gibt es den
fatalismus der aufgelöst werden müsste
in
aktion in gewisser weise fatalismus ja
sicherlich auch eine desillusionierung
dass man sagt naja die machen eh nix für
uns wir können machen was wir wollen
auch aus der erfahrung der vergangenheit
heraus viele hunderttausend menschen
sind zum beispiel gegen artikel 13
beziehungsweise artikel 17 diese
urheberrechtsreform der eu auf die
straße gegangen da die regierung
versprochen mit uns kommen keine upload
filter letztendlich kamen dann doch so
was wir upload filter man hat das gefühl
man wird nicht gehört und dann lässt man
es halt irgendwann sein freies for
future harten langen atem bewiesen der
hat sich ausgezahlt das merkt man jetzt
und dieser lange atem fehlt dann aber
vielleicht weil man sich um andere dinge
kümmern muss als junger mensch als
ständig auf die straße zu gehen und ich
finde auch dass ein bisschen viel
verlangt wir sind noch mal bei hajo
schumacher herr plus ist auch gleich
noch mal und fragen genau diese frage
wie können junge politiker wie kann die
politik vermeiden dass die gruppe
derjenigen die sagen ich erwarte da
jetzt sowieso nichts gutes mehr nicht
größer wird wir haben das demographische
die demografische herausforderung sagen
dass man so dass wir mehr ältere als
jüngere haben also demokratisch gesehen
sind wir älteren die mehrheit insofern
finde ich sehr problematisch die
generation immer gegeneinander
auszuspielen jede generation hat ihre
vollkosten und jede generation hat ihre
zurechnungsfähigen klugen menschen und
ein ein thema zum beispiel und das weiß
ich auch von vielen jungen menschen ist
riesengroß und wird auch in diesem
wahlkampf überhaupt nicht digital
angesprochen die digitalisierung ja wir
haben auch einen gesellschaftlichen
klimawandel diese polarisierung dieses
rum gehetze dieses gebaren nach klicks
diese das immer kleiner werden eines
kompromiss raumes ist ein riesengroßes
problem
das sind die reichsten unternehmen der
welt die ihr geld damit verdienen
gesellschaften zu zersetzen heute hat
facebook bekannt gegeben wir sperren
nach anderthalb jahren pandemie sperren
wir doch tatsächlich mal so ein paar
querdenker netzwerke weil die zur gewalt
aufrufen ja auch da macht die politik
überhaupt nichts ich würde an die vier
jungen vertreter einen wunsch äußern
wollen wir alle wissen dass dieser
bundestag jetzt schon mit 700 ungefähr
mdbs viel zu groß ist wir erwarten für
diese wahl 800 und womöglich wird das
bis zu 1000 die große koalition war
nicht in der lage sich selbst zu
reformieren in diesem bundestag bitte
junge menschen kriegt das hin
also darum das ist jetzt noch der appell
dass das parlament wieder verkleinert
wird ich fasse kurz zusammen und sie ihr
sagt nochmal ob ihr sie sich vorstellen
können alle demokratischen parteien
sollen miteinander regierungsfähig seien
sie sich vorstellen könnten an einem
regierungs tisch zu sitzen an einem
kabinettstisch zu sitzen
also für uns ist klar dass wir mit der
linkspartei um darf den nicht koalieren
werden das sagen wir auch klar vorher
sie können deswegen da ich hier keinen
von der linkspartei fdp sehe ja so oder
so werden man muss ja immer spreche ich
sei nur ich finde da noch ein satz sagen
weil ich das erst nein wir müssen leider
erhitzen sich nach durchs land geben
deshalb war ich für ein ja total dankbar